manuel merino en estos momentos está
recibiendo honores de los representantes
de las fuerzas armadas en su calidad de
jefe supremo y comandante de militar en
el país
manuel merino es un político y
empresario que ha estado relacionado a
las actividades de agricultura y
ganadería él ha comenzado su carrera
política en el partido acción popular
que es un movimiento de derecha él se
unió a ellos y acá ha generado una
carrera que lo ha llevado al parlamento
durante tres oportunidades él asumió
este cargo de presidente del congreso
justamente después de que fuera electo
con más de 5000 votos en el nuevo
parlamento que se inauguró este año
precisamente el 16 de marzo él salió a
la palestra y su característica ha sido
que ha dirigido las relaciones entre el
poder ejecutivo y el legislativo
he estado caracterizada por demasiado
tensa se podría decir a él se le ha
criticado mucho porque fue uno de los
principales propulsores del primer
proceso de vacancia presidencial de
martín vizcarra y justamente al haber
sido puesto de manifiesto que él llamó a
altos mandos de las fuerzas armadas
horas antes que se iniciara el proceso
de vacancia que residencial fue
duramente criticado es por eso que hay
protestas de rechazo en diversos lugares
del perú se estaba señalando que esta
transición digamos ha sido forzada por
el parlamento y se lo está denominando
como un golpe de estado encubierto nos
señalan que la fuerza de seguridad están
ejerciendo un control para tratar de
bloquear las protestas que tratan de
ingresar alrededor del palacio
legislativo francisco explícanos un poco
entonces el ambiente que ocurre detrás
usted y también de la importancia de
estas elecciones del próximo año donde
los fueron as orígenes del nuevo
congreso y presidente
manuel merino ha señalado que él va a
respetar el cronograma electoral
precisamente se tenía previsto que en
abril se realicen las elecciones
presidenciales y congresales ya hay un
cronograma establecido y lo que se
estaba temiendo era que quizás se
pudiese extender el periodo de
transición porque solamente su gobierno
está señalado para que sea ocho meses y
se transfiere el poder al ciudadano que
sea elegido el 28 de julio del 2021 en
estos momentos hay tropas de la fuerza
armadas del ejército la marina y la
aviación ellos están expresando el
reconocimiento al nuevo jefe de estado
esta es una inauguración presidencial
atípica podemos decir que en los últimos
cuatro años hay tres presidentes que han
juramentado y han sido impuestos con la
banda presidencial algunos analistas
políticos están señalando
que las protestas ciudadanas podrían ser
quizás el colorario o mejor dicho una
característica de lo que podría ser la
gestión de manuel merino rodeado del
descontento popular